la tâche n 14 n'est jamais vu l'avant
portugal parce que je travaille tout le
temps
c'est important qu'ils connaissent
qu'est ce que t'en sais qu'est ce que tu
fous là
j'ai regardé mes nièces
[Musique]
doucement sur la balançoire pense que
j'ai sur mais mal j'ai pas dit ça
elle a l'air triste ça ferait du bien
méchant prêté chez toi ça ferait du bien
de fermer un peu ta gueule je sois
gentil avec ma soeur tu nous force à
remuer la merde en réjouissent
[Musique]
il sait qu'il a été prêté me ressemble
dis maman la petite fille
ben c'est simple ich
on préfère du chat quand papa et maman
promis prendre
j'étais tellement content qu aux ethnies
comme un cadeau du ciel
[Musique]
emma
vous êtes no toki solide